now in the world of lockdown zoom calls
have become something of a way of life
but still not everyone quite gets it
right all of the time
one call has gone viral after a lawyer
attending a virtual hearing in front of
a judge
accidentally appeared as a cat mr ponton
i believe you have a
filter turned on in the video settings
uh you might want to uh
we're trying to can you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter i'm
here live that's not
i'm not a cat i i can i can see that
it's brilliant let's bring in this guy's
becky cuatro was in the newsroom this
morning um becky
explain exactly what's going on here i
have to say i mean technology is clearly
fantastic these days
as the poor lawyer who would
accidentally switch that filter on you
could see the terror
in the kitten's eyes yeah the anguish
in the cat's eyes the filter cat really
seemed to reflect poor mr ponton's
anguish rod ponton the lawyer there
really struggling
with technology and the judge was saying
you know we need to sort this out
mr ponton wanted to continue uh with the
hearing
sky news actually spoke to the judge in
that hearing judge
roy ferguson this is a time when people
are
are down and depressed and lonely
and angry at each other and at the
government
and this has been just a small little
glimpse
unintentional as it was by me
into what things need to be again
everyone is
enjoying it the feedback is all positive
people are happy to see it and they're
laughing
and i hear that that's something we need
more of
yeah the best line in that video has to
be when uh the lawyer feels a need to
clarify
that he's not a cat that was a filter
that he was using unintentionally one of
several filters you can get on zoom
probably should be reserved for calls
with family and friends not for work
definitely
not for a court hearing